[MUSIC PLAYING]
TONY KUCHIO: Buymore is an
electronic student discount
card that uses the near
field communication
technology to issue discounts
to students in high school
and university.
Buymore has 6,000
users, currently.
And it's across three different
universities in Kenya.
And we're looking
to expand it further
towards the end of the year.
JOHN OPIO: Well, in how we
started in the first three
months, we actually
gave out 1,000 cards
for free, just to
let the students get
a feel of the concept of getting
a discount at a favorite brand.
And so from that moment
is when we were also
collecting feedback
on what other places
they might want to go.
With NFC, we feel that it
cuts across-- at least,
in terms of
application and usage,
you can be able to do
a number of things.
With us, from
identification, or just,
maybe, tapping to check
your credit or tapping to
top-up your card.
And so we feel
that it's something
that we can scale to
other uses as well.
TONY KUCHIO: And
also, moving forward,
we're looking at a future
where you don't necessarily
need to have a Buymore card.
So say, if you have an NFC
phone, all you'd need to do
is download an application.
And then, you use your NFC
phone as your Buymore card,
as your discount card.
So those are the options
that NFC gave to us,
and why we decided
to exploit them.